[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hi friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact antibotics like penicillin
are chemicals effective at killing or
stopping the growth of a microscopic
disease causing bacteria ironically
History's Greatest miracle drug was
discovered quite by accident in 1928
Alexander Fleming Scottish physician and
microbiologist returned from vacation to
his messy laboratory at St Mary's
Hospital in London and he noticed
something odd he left some plates with
bacteria cultures on a bench in the
corner on examination he noticed one of
them was growing mold Fleming observed
that that the bacteria nearest to the
mold growing was dying something in the
mold was killing the bacteria Fleming
discovered the mold was penicilium one
of the top three most common Airborne
fungi it took years before his Discovery
was refined by others tested and
manufactured on a mass scale before
penicillin the number one killers in the
world were things like tuberculosis
pneumonia diarrhea scarlet fever menitis
infections from wounds or even surgery
penicillin's ability to cure people of
what were once fatal bacterial
infections has saved over 200 million
lives it's easy to understand why it's
called a miracle drug you know it tells
us Pastor Ross in the Bible that there's
a substance infinitely more powerful
than the strongest
antibiotics that's correct Pastor Doug
it is something that can not only clear
uh cure sickness but more importantly
the sickness of of sin
to Eternal death and of course we're
talking about the blood of Christ the
cross amen you can read a couple of
scriptures here Hebrews
9:14 how much more shall the blood of
Christ who through the eternal spirit
offered himself without spot to God
cleanse your conscience from dead Works
to serve the Living God and then there's
another powerful verse in Ephesians 1:7
in him we have Redemption through his
blood the Forgiveness of sins according
to to The Riches of his grace I remember
Pastor Ross when I first started looking
into the Christian religion I I thought
it's kind of gory they talked about
Power in the Blood and saved by the
blood and Washed by the blood and I
thought this is a bloody religion and
but then I came to understand that you
know the Bible says the life is in the
blood and Christ in giving his blood he
gave his life and we are washed by his
life and we are healed and empowered by
his life and his sacrifice of his life
life and so um in a sense he he gives us
a
transfusion of his Purity to heal us
from our disease so in that sense the
blood of Christ washes away our sin and
um maybe there's some people listening
out there that think I I need healing I
need salvation and forgiveness for my
sins and uh I think I could use a dose
of that cure we have a free offer that
talks about that we do a book is
entitled the high cost of the Cross
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks it's our free offer
this evening so take advantage of it all
you need to do is just call the number
6747 you can ask for offer number 156 or
just ask for it by name the high cost of
the cross it explains the gospel and
shares good news if you'd like to get a
digital version of the book just out
pound 250 with your smartphone again
just say Bible answers live and then say
High Cost of the Cross that's pound 250
with your phone and ask for that free
gift you know Pastor D probably one of
the most important truths that we find
in scripture centers on the cross
centers on that sacrificial death of
Jesus and uh just such an important
truth well before we go to the phone
lines we always like to start with
prayer and so let's do that now dear
Lord we thank you for this time once
again when we can open up the Bible and
study together this is your book Lord we
pray for the Holy Spirit to come and
guide us that same spirit that inspired
the prophets many years ago we ask that
that Spirit would got our hearts and our
minds be with those who are listening
wherever they might be in Jesus name
amen amen well our first call this
evening we've got Jerry listening in
Texas uh Jerry welcome to Bible answers
live good evening gentlemen uh I have a
question in my Bible readings this
morning and refers to numbers 24 and the
interactions between baet and balum I
don't know if it was in a um maybe an
insert from an INSP RI here but I
thought I understood that
bck used sorcery in a couple of his
attempts can you explain that to me yeah
well you have two characters that are
mentioned here in the Book of Numbers 24
and uh balum was a prophet of God now
keep in mind there were some Old
Testament prophets they knew the Lord
and the Lord spoke to them and they
weren't necessarily Jews um you know
Noah was technically a prophet and he
was not a Jew
so in Mesopotamia there was someone who
worshiped the true God his name was
balum but uh while he started out good
he ended up going bad well he was known
to the other kings as a man that God
spoke through and so BAC knowing that
God was with Israel BAC was the king of
the moabites he thought look if I can't
if I can't defeat them with natural
means I'm going to Fight Fire with Fire
they've got god with them and maybe I
can get a prophet of God to curse them
that was is reasoning and so he you know
they were used to back then paying uh
psychics and Sorcerers to try to cast
spells and they they told balam will you
come cast the spell or curse Israel and
he said no God's bless them I can't they
kept offering him more and more money
and he got tempted he wanted the honor
and the money they were offering so he
said well I I have to say what the Lord
says but I'll go if you you know if you
insist and so um every time he opens his
mouth to try to curse Israel blessings
come out in fact one of the blessings of
balum is where it said a star will rise
out of Jacob and it's probably the wise
men in Mesopotamia where balum was from
that were reading that when they came
searching for the Christ child so but
balum was not using sorcery bik the king
of the moabites was hoping that he would
use some kind of Witchcraft or sorcery
to curse them so hopefully that helps a
little bit Jerry it's a very interesting
story where the donkey ends up talking
to the prophet m all right thank you
next caller that we have is Isaiah
listening in Texas Isaiah welcome to
Bible answers live yes hello thank you
pastors for both taking my call I really
appreciate it and your
question yes yes sir my question is um
referring to acts
26:24 it's referring over to uh when
Paul was feeling beside
himself and um I guess with all the
learning it was driving him insane could
you please elaborate on that Paul is
making his defense before fesus who is
one of the Roman rulers that is going to
decide whether or not to set him free or
to punish him or to send him to Rome and
as Paul is talking to him about Jesus
and the
resurrection aesus says Paul you're
beside yourself beside yourself is a
term that's used to mean you've lost
your mind and he's saying you're beside
yourself much learning has driven you
mad Paul was very educated he said you
spent too much time reading the
prophecies and you're getting caught up
in it and you're not balanced you've
gone mad so well Paul was not beside
himself and he was not um crazy and
though he was very wise and so he goes
on to say in verse 25 I am not mad most
noble
fesus but I'm speaking the words of
truth and reason for the king before
whom I also speak and he's talking there
to Agrippa he said he knows the words
that I say are true so there's a couple
of rulers that are listening to him and
and uh one of when he talks about the
resurrection he says you're crazy you
know if you look at that same passage
there is a cross reference where Paul
now in 1 Corinthians chap 1: 21 speaking
of Christ and him crucified he said to
the Jew it's a stumbling block and to
the Greeks it's foolishness yeah so you
can understand how here you have this
Roman governor who talks about or hears
about the resurrection he says that
that's craziness out of your mind Paul
said well to the unbeliever it's
foolishness but to those of us who are
saved it's eternal life you know it's
wonderful promise good point so okay
thank you Isaiah we've got uh Joan
listening in Australia Joan welcome to
Bible aners live hello thank you for
taking my call my question um tonight
is where in the Bible does it say we
scream or vote people to be members in
or out of a church well I don't think
you'll find the word
uh vote um the teaching that people need
to be clear uh before they added you
know before baptism Philip asked I'm
sorry the Ethiopian treasur asked Philip
and I think this is Acts chapter 8 he
said what prevents me from being
baptized and he said well if you believe
with all your heart so one thing is you
got to believe to be part of the church
um you need to be willing to obey God's
Commandments in Matthew chap 28 Jesus
said go therefore teach All Nations or
certain teaching teaching what he says
teaching them to observe all things that
I've commanded you so a person should
not be part of the church or be baptized
if they don't believe the Commandments
of God and then Paul leader says that if
someone uh and Jesus says it also in
Matthew 18 if someone will not listen to
the authority of the church then they
should be put out and treated like uh an
Infidel I think he says a Publican uh
Paul talks in 1 Corinthians 7 about a
man that was sleeping with his
stepmother
and he said you need to put that man out
he was you know clearly bringing shame
on the cause and uh so there's a
criteria and then when they were
baptized in Acts chapter 2 it says they
were added to the church and the term
they're added means like brought within
the fold they're becoming part of
something so you see there's a criteria
for coming in and for going out and it's
believing the teachings of Jesus does
that make sense
Joan thank you all right thanks so much
appreciate your question all right we
got Britney listening in California
Britney welcome to Bible ansers live hey
hey hi how are you doing
Britney oh pretty
good and so what's your question
tonight yeah my question is should a
Christian celebrate sud Shazad day well
I you know there's there there are some
people that are notable in society you
know there's uh Martin Luther King's Day
they've got President's Day that is
actually honoring both Washington and
Lincoln So when you say celebrate you
know there's no no religious uh
celebration going on on any of those
days uh people might want to you know uh
enjoy and commemorate their
achievements but um uh you know there's
no mandate in the Bible to celebrate uh
I guess anybody but Jesus matter of fact
we don't even really have command
remember Christmas that's more of a
tradition than a command so um yeah
nothing in the Bible says to celebrate
Caesar Chavez Day so hey thanks Britney
hope that helps we've got Deborah in
Canada Deborah welcome to Bible ances
live hi pastors how are you doing great
thanks for calling good I have a
question about the
Raven the bird the Raven uh I know Noah
in Genesis 8:7 let it out of the he was
the first bird to let be let out and in
Kings First Kings The Raven was the
Ravens were used to feed Elijah I was
just wondering if there was any
significance as to why God would choose
what we know in the mosaic laws an
unclean Bird yeah that is interesting I
think that the the reason that the Lord
chose the Raven is um uh first of all
Elijah and Noah were not told to eat
Ravens
um the Ravens are probably they're in
the Corvette family and they're the um
smartest one of the smartest birds I
think their intelligence is uh they say
even above a dog they know how to use
tools uh they live a long time they
grieve when another Raven dies and uh
they can actually some Ravens can learn
to mimic certain sounds like you know
parrots do so um they're extremely
bright birds and I think God guided them
into the Palace of Ahab to take food
from Ahab and bring it to uh Elijah I
can't prove that but it's fun to think
so yeah and they're what do you call it
Ravens are kind of omnivores so they
could bring almost
anything it's not like a hummingbird
just going to get nectar and it's a big
bird so carry yeah car things so all
right thank you Deborah good point we've
got Gary in Illinois Gary welcome to the
program thank you are we entering the
first trumpet judgment you know
considering the recent uh extreme
weather like wildfires in Texas and hail
storms I get this from Revelation 8:7
yeah I don't know Pastor Ross you want
to address read the verse it says and
the first Angel sounded and there was
hail followed with mingled with blood
and it says that were thrown to the
Earth and a third of the trees were
burnt up and the green grass was burnt
up of course the Book of Revelation is a
is a prophetic book and it's filled with
symbols right from the very beginning of
the book all the way to the end uh you
talk about horses Galloping across the
sky and you got a red horse and a white
horse and a black horse and a pale horse
and a lot of symbolisms that find seven
heads you don't see that every day yeah
that's right and beasts coming up from
the sea and the Earth and so yeah this
is part of the trumpets and the trumpets
kind of go through uh the history from
the time of Christ all the way through
until our time and the fifth trumpet
it's got talking about trees being burnt
up and green grass being burnt up in the
Bible trees often associated with people
and green grass would be a symbol for
people once again or large groups of
people it's really talking about a
judgment that was to come upon those
part of the Roman Empire that had um
persecuted the Christians there was
attacks from the various Barbarian
tribes that entered the land you also
have the Muslim tribes all the Muslim
movement under the Ottoman Empire and
the Turks that were coming in entering
into Europe so that had a broader
historical application uh with reference
to this fifth trumpet not so much a
literal application although you know
the Bible does speak about the Earth
getting old like a garment and talks
about the Sea and the waves roaring as
signs connected with the coming of
Christ or close to the coming of Christ
and yes there are changes in our
environment and I think there are signs
Bible speaks of earthquakes diverse
places so there are things happening in
the natural world that are warning signs
as to the imminent coming of Christ yeah
and of course um it tells us in
Revelation that God will destroy those
that destroy the Earth M and you can
just see that the fires and everything
that's happening a lot of them are
man-made and of course things are a
little different nowadays uh you know
back 100 200 years ago these forest
fires would burn almost all summer long
in the mountains here in California and
they would burn out a lot of the
underbrush whereas you know in our times
always yeah we're putting fires out and
so it's only increasing the vegetation
that can burn it's dry and so yeah
things have changed environment's
changed all right well thank you
appreciate that Gary Glenn listening in
Ohio Glenn welcome to Bible ances live
thanks again for taking my call yeah you
know when God spoke to Noah in the 11th
chapter of Genesis he told him to get
busy and replenish the Earth and all
translations agree with that
replenishing of the Earth but when you
go to Genesis 1: 128 where Yahweh is
speaking to Adam and Eve he tells them
also according to the King James
translation to replenish the earth I see
that as either a blemish in the King
James version of the Bible or something
else that needs to be talked about can
you help me yeah well uh when God tells
them to fill the the word I've got and
I'm reading the new King James he said
that they should fill the Earth and um
you know God told Adam and Eve I want
you to populate the Earth originally
they were in the garden after sin they
were evicted from the garden are you
thinking that there was maybe a
population before Adam and Eve that
needed to be
replaced I think that might be worth of
consideration because it's the only
translation that talks about to Adam and
Eve of re replenishing the
Earth yeah well I think like I said this
uh this translation and by the way there
the King James translation while it is
wonderful is not perfect it was done by
men they were not angels that translated
theing King James Bible and there are a
couple places where they maybe didn't
have the best choice of words or there's
some inconsistency this is a place where
I think that the word be fruitful and
fill the Earth is more appropriate
because there's nothing in the Genesis
record that says that there was a
civilization before Adam and Eve that
needed to be replaced it's goes
sequentially from the days of creation
to Adam's creation to Eve to the fall
there's no other scenario of some other
race that was is wiped out that needed
to be replaced that's right can squeeze
in there sin the consequence of sin is
death and we know according to the Bible
that sin started with Adam and Eve no if
they were the ones yeah if they were the
ones to replenish the Earth meaning they
were to replace a population beforehand
that had died how would they have died
if there had been no sin so good point
and if you look at the other
translations it says uh be fruitful
multiply and fill the Earth and subdue
it so I think that's a better
translation there next caller that we
have is Henry listening in New York
Henry welcome to Bible answers live my
question is if you go to heaven and your
name written in the Book of Life do you
have to take communion before you get
into heaven well it you know Jesus does
say in the I think it's both Gospel of
Matthew it's repeated in 2
Corinthians that uh the Lord's Supper
celebrating the and the Lord's Supper
was like an extension of the Passover
the Passover was you know this angel of
judgment passes over because of the
blood of the Lamb well when Jesus comes
he knows he is the Passover Lamb and he
said except you eat my flesh and drink
my blood you have no life in you John
chapter 6 so that's talking about it's a
symbol for accepting the life of Jesus
and that his blood would cleanse us from
sin and the teachings of the New
Testament the New Covenant that's what
the the grape juice is a symbol of so a
Believer should want to participate
first of all and being part of a church
family and communion now in our church
sometimes we've got some seniors that uh
well I guess every Church you have some
people that are shut in they can't make
it and when we have communion we have
elders and pastors that'll go and take
it to their home and so that they can
participate but it there's only a couple
of sacred ordinances that Jesus left the
church and one of them is baptism course
you got marriage baptism and you've got
the communion service so it's it's
certainly it's a a ratification of our
faith that should be repeated uh
whenever the church comes together in
that
capacity okay thank you do you have to
know wait do you have to do that to go
to heaven there'll be people in heaven
that maybe didn't have an opportunity
for sure but why a Believer would not
want to is a concern okay all right we
got Lloyd in Arkansas Lloyd welcome to
Bible ances live hello thank you for uh
having me on and to answer my question
yeah my question is is God protecting
Satan and if so what is he protecting
him from well when you say is God
protecting Satan uh Satan is living
under an impending
judgment and Satan is also he is
restricted in what he can access the
Bible tells us in Revelation 12 that
Satan was cast down to the Earth so the
devil's Rebellion against God has been
limited to our planet and so as far as
God protecting him well God gives all of
his creatures life uh and people that
choose to turn away from God their
initial life comes from God he doesn't
God does not exterminate somebody as
soon as they say I don't love you
anymore otherwise we see half the more
than half the population would expire
right away so people are sustained by
God um he's the one who gives grace to
the people that even curse him they
couldn't live or take another breath or
have another heartbeat without God so in
that sense the devil is still sustained
by the initial life God gave him but the
devil's not being protected by God I
don't think he needs much protection as
far as um he's the highest of the Angels
there's no other Angel that's harassing
him in that way so I don't know I
hopefully I'm answering your question
Lloyd Pastor thank you very much all
right thanks so much you take care all
right next caller that we have is er
Frank in New York erf Frank welcome to
Bible ansers live good evening Pastor
Doug and pastor Ross I have a question
in regards to uh the Bible about an
issue that has to do with um how you
believe in Jesus uh on on certain
occasions uh there is this South African
woman who told me that the way Jesus
revealed himself during the persecution
of Herod in Africa that she has the
right to celebrate and display a
understanding of her symbolic adherence
to what Jesus did in uh in namur now I
have always believed in in the what
Jesus preached in this in Galilee and I
just want to know Pastor Doug in the
Bible does it say that we have to wear
any type of apparel or indicative uh
symbols uh uh indicating that we're
Christians and we believe in God and the
Bible that way because in the Bible it
says that it's harder for a rich man to
enter the kingdom of God than than
someone who is poor yeah all right so is
there any criteria on what we should or
shouldn't wear given in the Bible you
know God does not uh order us to wear a
particular costume now when the priests
in the Old Testament there was a certain
apparel that the priest would wear of
course the purpose of the Old Testament
Temple has been fulfilled when Christ
died on the cross the veil was rent
Jesus said your house has left you
desolate and so the the um ironic
priesthood right now does not exist in
that they're not sacrificing Lambs so
there's no uniform there are principles
that God gives in his word for every
believer and those principles have to do
with uh neatness
modesty uh the Bible tells us that you
know we we should uh not be wearing and
this is men and women should not be
adorned with the outward adorning of
gold and and apparel and costly Ray and
Paul talks about you know women where
ing pearls and having elaborate haird uh
you know God's people shouldn't dress so
frumpy that we attract attentions
because because of our being out of date
but we also shouldn't try and be
impressing people with our money by the
clothes we wear there should be humility
in that neat clean modest those are the
principles that God shares we got a book
on that by the way on um jewelry how
much is too much a person can get when
they call the resource line number to
call is 800 83567 47 you can ask for
that book it's called jewelry how much
is too much we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in Canada or the US so call and
askk all right friends we're getting
ready for our halftime break so we want
to encourage you to pay attention to
these important messages that are coming
we'll be back taking more Bible
questions in just a few
[Music]
moments stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly hi my name is Diamond Garcia and
I from the beautiful islands of Hawaii I
was raised in a very dysfunctional
family like most families being in that
environment I would lie cheat steal rob
houses chea in school and tests and
lying to teachers and getting into
fights and all kinds of
stuff one day I was asked to take this
little box of something and I had to
walk down the road and give it to
someone and they would give me money and
I walk back home and I later realized I
was dealing
drugs growing up in that environment I
thought that you know being an adult was
a life of drinking and smoking and
partying and that's just what adults
did when I looked at my family and saw
the road that they were going down
getting arrested getting beaten up
coming home drunk and puking all over
the floor I just didn't want that for
myself
growing up I had a grandma who was
baptized as a Christian in her 20s but
then she wasn't a real practicing
Christian and so one day I was at her
house and there was a box of various
books and I went to the bottom of that
box and found a book called The Great
controversy and I picked it up and I
said this is interesting and I opened to
the first page of that book and it said
if thou Hast
known I had no clue what it meant and so
I said you know what forget this I put I
put the book down I just walked away did
my thing but then something told me you
know Diamond go back to that book and so
I went back to the book picked it up
went to the last two chapters and I read
it and I said to my grandmother I said
what church is this from I want to go to
that church so so she brought me down to
the local church and I walk in from the
back door and the piano's off key people
are off key it's like man this is really
kind of I don't want to be
here and I got to the front of the
church and I sat down I was was
listening to the sermon and the whole
service it was so boring to me but then
someone gives me this set of DVDs and it
was it was called the prophecy
code it was through watching Doug
Bachelor explain the truths found in the
Bible that really brought me to Christ
and brought me to realize that you know
what there is a life better than my
family's life my second week at church
on Sabbath there was one person there he
basically told me hey Diamond do you
want to make some money
and I said sure I said what do you do he
says well I'm a CP Porter we go door too
and we sell Christian books I said oh
okay well that sounds interesting I do
want to make some money too and so he
said okay well why don't you come with
me we drove out to the neighborhood
parked the car and that night was just
raining it was pouring and pouring it
could not stop raining he prayed he said
God this is diamond's first night if
it's your will stop the rain so we can
go knocking on doors and as soon as he
said amen the range just stopped I was
just thinking in my head is this guy a
prophet or what I mean he just prayed
and asked God and it happened and so I
was so I was so happy I grabbed the
books and I went to the first door and
the first door I went to the person gave
me 50 bucks that night was actually a
big night for me because it was where I
saw God's power work and stopping the
rain and people actually giving me lots
of money I then became a CP Porter or
caner and I saved money to pay for my
way through Academy and when my church
began to see how God was using me they
immediately recognized that it was God's
spirit moving and they put me you know
preaching and teaching and sharing my
faith and I've been engaged in Ministry
for the past 6 to seven years now and
God has taken me all over the world and
multiple continents sharing my testimony
how God has brought me out of Darkness
Into His Marvelous Light that's a total
contrast as to how I was before and now
you know it's a total
contrast my name is diamond and amazing
amazing facts has helped to change my
[Music]
life you're listening to Bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of God and
his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for get practical answers about
the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode episode if you'd like
answers to your Bible related questions
on the air please call us next Sunday
between 7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and if you have tuned
in somewhere along the way this is as
the title hints a live International
interactive Bible study you can give us
a call call if you have a Bible question
the number is 800 God says that's 800
7297 with your Bible questions my name
is Doug Bachelor my name is John Ross
and we have a number of folks are
standing by with their Bible question
but Pastor Doug before we go to the
phone lines we want to remind you of our
free offer for that we have talks about
the cross it's called The High Cost of
the Cross and we want to send that to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835
6747 you can ask for the high cost of
the Cross just offer number 156 you can
also receive a digital download of that
book by simply dialing pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible aners live and then
ask for the high cost of the Cross and
we'll be able to send you a digital copy
of the book you can read it you can
share it with somebody else going to go
back to the phone lines we've got press
listening in Texas and he's got a
question about watching Christian
programs Preston welcome to the
program hello hi thanks for
calling uh yes so my question was is it
wrong for Christians to watch chrisan
programs like the chosen the TV show The
Chosen all right well um I'm a little
biased if you ask about watching
Christian programs because we're
producing one at this very moment so
there's no sin in taking in spiritual
material whether you're reading or
whether you're watching or listening TV
is just one of the mediums that
communicates and so uh that's a very
powerful medium at the same time you
want to um you know have a filter about
what you do and don't watch there are
some Christian programs out there that I
don't watch they're you know these
pastors quite frankly that they they're
doing this Prosperity Gospel I think
it's extortion of a type spiritual
extortion and um you notice we don't
spend a lot of time begging for money on
this program and promising people Fame
and Fortune and health and wealth if
they do so I there's some things I won't
watch because I just think they're so
unbiblical there's some good Ministries
and ministers out there I don't expect
them to agree with me in every point and
they they've got a lot of great uh
material and so you kind of eat the
melon and you spit out the seeds and
they probably feel that way about me um
now when you're talking about the Chosen
and I've only seen to be honest a few
excerpts um I I've found in my own
experience Pastor Ross may have some
thoughts on this that when Hollywood
tries to recreate Jesus or biblical
stories they almost never can get close
to the real thing or it's always
distorted in one way or the other have
some good things come out of that well
I'm sure there are people that haven't
thought about the life and teachings of
Jesus that watch this and you could
point to some good things um I but
personally I I think that there's a a d
D when we we start getting our
information about Christ in his ministry
from what I known someone told me I
should watch it I watched a little bit
and uh I saw right away they were
embellishing the story with things that
were not in the Bible which is always
suspect but uh you know I'm not here to
condemn I I commend people that are
trying to communicate the gospel I don't
know that's a rambling answer but any
thoughts you want to r agre p you know
it's uh you go out
well I think they actually they they
actually say that they're not trying to
be perfectly faithful to you know what
the Bible says they do take Liberties to
kind of add in and uh you know there's
some extra stories added extra
personalities added that's not in the
gospel account and uh on the one hand
you got to be careful because you know
the Bible talks about a really true
story something that really happened
when you read about the gospel you read
about Christ you read about the apostles
that That's History that's that's real
you don't want to create the scene where
that almost becomes more of a novel type
scenario so yeah I agree pastor we got
to be careful you start embellishing on
the the truth and people can get
distracted by the embellishment yeah
that's true and miss the main point so
all right thank you Preston a verse in
the Bible Philippians 4:8 finally
Brethren whatever things are true and he
goes on to say dwell on these things MH
yeah okay next caller that we have is
Sandra listening in Pennsylvania and
she's got a question about Joshua and
the angel that you read about in
Zachariah 3 Sandra welcome to the
program hi good evening thank you for
taking my call evening hi bear um so the
other day um recently I heard a sermon
in regards to Zechariah Chapter 3 um
wonderful sermon and but I was a little
confused as to who Joshua is and who the
angel of the Lord is cuz I always
thought that Joshua represents Christ
and that also the angel of the Lord also
represents Christ pre-incarnate so um I
was just trying to figure out you know
who's represented in that chapter all
right good well in Zechariah Chapter 3
there's a vision it says he showed me
Joshua this is verse one the high priest
standing before the angel of the Lord
and Satan standing at his right hand to
oppose or that word is to accuse him you
go to Revelation 12 it calls Satan the
accuser of the Brethren and in the Book
of Job there's the devil accusing job
before God and the devil is our accuser
in Christ as our defense attorney so the
angel of the Lord is the one that
rebukes the devil in Zachariah now there
really was a high priest in Israel
during zachariah's time and his name was
Joshua it's interesting the name Joshua
is the name Jesus in Hebrew it's
actually Yeshua and you've got Joshua
who led the children of Israel into the
Promised Land he's like our general and
our um our judge and then you got Joshua
the high priest that led the children of
Israel from Babylon back to the promised
land so they're both types of Christ and
the priest would bear the sins of the
people so Joshua's got these dirty
clothes because of the sins of the
people and the devil's accusing and in
the story his filthy clothes are taken
away by the angel of the Lord and he's
given clean garments and it's a symbol
of the cleansing from sin so you're
pretty close from what you said Sandra
to uh having a right interpretation I'm
not sure what you may have heard someone
else say but um yeah this is a story
about The Plan of Salvation it tells us
that the angel of the Lord stood by and
he said you can read in verse 6 now if
you'll walk in my ways this is after his
filthy garments are taken away if you'll
walk in my ways and if you will keep my
command then you will judge my house
likewise have charge of my courts and I
will give you places to walk among those
who stand here in other words you'll be
here in heaven so it's a wonderful
promise so in this Parable or in this
chapter in this Vision Joshua would
represent the people and the angel of
the Lord would represent Christ right
but like you say there's there's almost
a dual application because yes our high
priest is Jesus but in this context
Joshua represents the people right okay
very good thank you good question Sandra
we got Charlie listening in Arizona and
he has a question about Exodus chap 20:
10 Charlie welcome to the program hi
guys how are you this evening good how
can we help you Exodus
20 uh verse 10 it says God created
everything in six days right and you
have to rest on the Sabbath and he
starts listening you your son your
daughter your manservant your female
servant your cattle everything but
there's no mention of a wife well yeah I
think that uh husbands and wives are
included Ed in the admonition when God
gives the Ten Commandments it tells us
that the men and women wash their
clothes husbands and wives and they came
before the Lord and they heard the Lord
saying these words audibly so the
command is not just given to the man the
Commandment is given to the the parents
that's why later it says honor your
father and your mother and so I think
it's
understood that U yeah people are to
rest from their regular labor there is a
verse earlier where it says B what
you're going to bake and boil what
you're going to boil and ostensibly you
know the women were doing a lot of the
cooking back then and they were to be
resting they were to get that work done
ahead of time so the command's all
encompassing I think for the family M
the stranger the cattle everybody was
the rest and it does appear that you
know when it specifically mentions the
list like you say your son your daughter
your servants a male servant female
servant your cattle the Strang you it's
within your Gates it's it's people under
your um under your control uh those who
you can direct and uh definitely that
would include all of the members of the
family well he's got a point it's hard
to direct your wife though well y yeah
maybe
uh that last
statement but it would it would include
everyone in your household right is the
idea behind that all right thank you
Charlie we've got Giovani listening from
Idaho and he's got a question from
Deuteronomy 33 giavon welcome to the
program hi there pastors how are you
this evening hey great thank you um
awesome so my question is actually in
regards to Deuteronomy
233 okay and um it's
about David and how he is King and I'm
just kind of wondering how he's King
when Ruth is a moabit right let me read
this for our friends that are listening
uh the moabites had attacked the
Israelites and gave them a hard time and
so there was a curse pronounced on them
and you can read in Deuteronomy 23:3 an
ammonite or a moabit shall not enter the
Assembly of the Lord even to the 10th
Generation none of his descendants shall
enter the Assembly of the Lord forever
because they did not meet you with bread
or water on the road when you came out
of Egypt because they hired against you
balum the son of beor from peor of
Mesopotamia to curse you um and yet Ruth
and it has not been 10 Generations from
when this was given no I don't think it
had been um yeah I can almost trace the
genealogy from Boaz was the son of
Salomon who was the maybe one of the
spies of Joshua so yeah it wasn't 10
Generations yet and um yet she was a
moabit and then she is the grandmother
or a great-grandmother of
David so um and she was allowed into the
congregation the the command does not
Eclipse an earlier command that if
someone converted to the god of uh the
Israelites that they were welcome and so
Ruth she said your God is my God so she
converted and um they had that law that
it's saying you could be friends with a
moabit up until they did this they could
have stayed
moabites but and you could do business
with them but after they H tried to
curse Israel there was a curse
pronounced for 10 Generations how long
would that be 40 time 10 400 years mhm
okay thank you good question let's see
we've got um Regina listening in Oregon
Regina welcome to the
program hi thank you thank you I um so I
do have a question actually I've been
asking this question myself but I didn't
not know how to
answer and someone asking asking me in J
jesa when God created Lucifer because he
did create the Lucifer when Lucifer
choose to do the wrong where did he know
the that wrong will
wrong coming from you know how do how do
because God create only the right things
love and everything everything was
perfect what where how you okay I'm
sorry how did he know to pick the wrong
you know what I mean yeah I think I know
what you mean Regina yeah um of course
God made everything good the Bible tells
us in James every good and perfect gift
uh comes from God and Jesus said God is
good and God does not tempt neither is
he tempted God cannot not do anything
bad because he is perfect and he's good
so God made good creatures but he made
them where they're they're built with a
risky freedom and that freedom to love
is given to all of his intelligent
creatures and Lucifer was given the same
freedom to love but in order to love
you've got to have the ability to choose
to not love God can't make you with
forced love built in it ceases to be
love if you can't choose it you become a
robot so Lucifer was given this he chose
to love himself more than God and it he
just kept nurturing that and it probably
went from an early inclination he knew
something was wrong but he kept
cherishing this self-love until he
pretty soon he put himself on the throne
and he wanted to destroy God and he
became ruled by
selfishness God is love Satan in a word
is
selfish and it's all about his pride and
his selfishness so
yeah God made him per perfect he made
him free he chose to love himself more
and he became corrupt through it and we
got a study guide It's called did God
create a devil and it answers all of
these questions a good great study and
we want to encourage anyone who wants to
learn more about this just call and ask
the number is 800 835 6747 you can ask
the study God is called did God create
the devil you can also D pound 250 on
your smartphone and say Bible answers
live and then ask for that study guide
did God created a devil we'll send it to
you study it and you'll be blessed next
caller that we have is Eric and he's
listening in Colorado and he has a
question about spirits Eric welcome to
the
program hi thank you for acting my call
yes um I see and hear Spirits does this
mean that I'm
lost you he hear and see spirits uh well
it means the devil the devil's probably
trying to get you of course he's trying
to get everybody but um you know I think
there are some godly people in the Bible
that uh they saw spirits that the devil
was trying to spook them and so because
the devil's trying to harass you or
frighten you does not automatically mean
you're lost uh it means that the devil's
trying to distract you or confuse you or
frighten
you um whether you are saved or lost is
something that you and the Lord only
know if if you've um come to Jesus and
surrendered your life to Jesus then uh
keep your eyes fixed on him if the Devil
Comes around in the name of the Lord
rebuke the devil do not give him ground
if there's something in your life that's
opening the door to the devil you know I
I've got a friend that was seeing all
kinds of Spooks and demons and they
spend all their time watching scary
movies these diabolical movies and I
thought well no wonder you're watching
ghost movies and um you're kind of
opening the door to the devil so close
any Avenues in your life where you're
creating a bridge for the devil to come
in and haunt or or tempt or frighten you
and um reconsecrate your life to the
Lord every day Paul said I Die daily
that means you got to be born again
every day okay great thank you we've got
coret listening from Connecticut and
coret has a question about working on
Sabbath yes coret welcome to the program
good night evening yes I was asking when
is it okay to work on the Sabbath well
uh there are obviously Christian
hospitals
that have people they care for you know
Jesus said it's better to do good on the
Sabbath day and so if you're ministering
to somebody who's struggling with some
dire sickness then that's appropriate
you know I know dentists that uh they
love the Lord but they'll get a call
from someone that's in agony from a
toothache they'll on the Sabbath day
they'll open their shop usually free of
charge and they'll go and and either
help them right then or at least help
them with some temporary relief where
they can do major surgery or whatever
they need later I don't know of any that
will say let me adjust your braces
because that's kind of an elective thing
that you can schedule another day but
when someone's in pain or suffering if
someone's in the hospital they need
doctors nurses and people to care for
them um my wife is a physical therapist
and she hasn't worked uh in a hospital
for years but when she did some people
had surgery on Friday and they needed to
have physical therapy immediately the
next day and so she would work and she
would not keep that pay she just donate
it to the Lord so there are emergency
situations you know if you're a fireman
you should try to schedule your Sabbath
free let someone else be on duty then so
you can rest but if there's a forest
fire you hop in your truck and you go
save people so even the Jews when
they're attacked at attacked on their
Sabbath day the soldiers can't say well
we'll start defending the country when
the Sun goes down so there are emergency
situations but they should be the rare
exception and not the rule um does that
make sense coret yeah it does all right
thank you so much appreciate it thanks
for your question all right next caller
that we have is Larry listening in
Michigan Larry welcome to the
program hi hi Larry thanks for
calling yeah U I got a
question how does a person know because
I know in Matthew Jesus was talking
about those who speak against the spirit
you know the imparable sin but how's the
person really know if they committed it
because sometimes I
wonder um but yet I feel guilty about a
lot of things so I'm I'm a little
confused and when I ask for forgiveness
I sometimes like Is that real I got
questions about
that so I just like to know about the um
I just hope I didn't like push the Holy
Spirit Away for that you know well you
know every time we sin we may grieve the
Holy Spirit but that does not mean you
grieved it away where it's
unforgivable uh so the very fact you're
calling means the holy spirit is
striving in your heart uh so I I would
not be worried that you've committed the
unpardonable sin I would be concerned
God wants you to have peace the Lord
wants you to believe that he will
forgive your sins and that he'll give
you power to live a new life you know
Christ doesn't ask us to do anything
without giving us the power to do it
when God says reent come to me I'll give
you rest' you turn from your sins you
confess your sins and he says I'll give
you peace and rest and victory and a new
life you believe that and you're going
to have peace and you'll have evidence
in your life that God is working in your
life and that will confirm the promises
of God also you know we have a book
Pastor Doug is called what is the
unpardonable sin and we encourage you to
take a look at that uh I think you'll
enjoy it uh the number to call is 8835
6747 and just ask for it it's called
what is the unpardonable sin we'll it to
you or you can just dial pound 250 on
your cell phone say Bible answers live
and then ask for the book by name what
is the unpardonable sin we got Joyce in
Florida uh Joyce welcome to the program
we have just a few moments but you have
a question about the punishment of the
wicked yes praise the Lord I love your
program oh thank you um yes uh I would
like to know um will there be degrees of
punishment in hell and if so where is
that uh located in the Bible Well I'm
looking up for you right now uh yes
there will be differences uh s d r i p I
added an extra letter in there hang on
here I'm typing something in my computer
I just can't spell Luke 1248 you found
it is that the one you beat me well no
I'm looking at Luke 12 yeah 4748 y it
says that servant who knew his master's
will and did not prepare himself or do
according to his will he will beaten
with be beaten with many stripes and
then it also says that those that did
not know their Master's will are beaten
with few Stripes so stripes are when
they used to whip a person it would
leave stripes on their back and that was
a whipping really and so Jesus is
basically saying those who were guilty
for much suffer more than those who were
less accountable and did not know so um
uh yes there are varying degrees of
reward and so there are varying degrees
of punishment
um Jesus says one of the last verses in
the Bible behold I come my reward is
with me to give to every man according
to his works so Adolf Hitler is going to
suffer More Than People of uh lesser
crimes so hopefully that helps you with
us Joyce does that make sense give about
the enlightenment all right you're
you're welcome God bless and we thank
you for your call uh Pastor Ross we have
time for one more quick one all right we
got Ron listening in uh let's see
Alabama Ron welcome to the
program yes good evening thank you for
taking my call yeah uh my question has
to do with Dina the daughter of Jacob
and Leah and mentioned in Genesis 34
could she somehow represent the church
you know how you have literal Israel and
the tribes the children of Israel then
you have spiritual Israel could Dina
represent the spiritual body of the
church being one of Jacob's you know
descendants I think you're on to
something and the story that Ron is
referring to is found there in Genesis
34 where Dina the only daughter listed
of Jacob's children everyone else was a
son that when they were living near
sheam she went out to visit the other
ladies of the land and maybe do some
shopping and young man took her and I
don't think he raped her but he took
advantage of her and he said he wanted
to marry her he loved her but um that's
kind of what the pagans had done to the
Israelites through intermarriage they
kind of lost their purity and so there
is an analogy there very perceptive Ron
I've never actually preached on that but
just as I was listening to you talk I
think there's more there under the
surface and you never hear that uh Dina
got married again and it doesn't really
tell about her having a family after
that so it it changed the course of her
life listening friends you know in just
a moment we're going to sign off and say
farewell to those listening listening on
satellite radio and then um those of you
who are listening on landbase stations
we always stay on for a few more minutes
to do rapid fire Bible questions that
come in via the Internet so you can
email us questions some people have
questions but they say I'm afraid to to
get on the air well you can email your
questions we'll take a few of them at
the end of each program and you'll see
the number there on the screen the email
address is B questions amazingfacts.org
but before we say farewell to the
audience at large you know we do these
programs because we want to share the
good news and that good news is that God
sent his son into the world to take the
punishment for all the sins of the world
and he wants you to be in his kingdom he
desperately wants you to be saved but we
need to make a decision to say Lord uh
I'm not doing a very good job running my
life I'm willing to surrender my life to
you I believe you have a plan for me I
would like to be forgiven of my sins
it's our prayer that everybody listening
will do that even right now make that
decision then go and sign up for the
amazing facts Bible study course at
amazingfacts.org we'll be back for the
others thank you for listening to
today's broadcast we hope you understand
your Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends and welcome back again to
our email Bible questions past to De
we've got a few great questions this
evening and of course if you'd like to
send us an email Bible question it's Bal
questions amazingfacts.org
Genesis 6:6 says that God repented but
numbers 23:19 says that God does not
repent how do we explain
this yeah well I I think that different
things are being meant here when it says
in Genesis 6 that God repented it's
talking about when sin was in the world
it grieved God in his heart and he was
sorry not sorry CU he had sinned but he
was sorry that he made man his plan for
the paradise and man to have this
happiness and man made in his creatures
sin and the devil had totally
interrupted that and there was just
misery on the planet and violence and so
that grieve God at his heart that's
different from uh God U saying oops I
made a mistake in repenting and that
respect um God knows everything nothing
surprises himh and um and God doesn't
repent for sin because he does not sin
he's pure and perfect okay next question
that we have is I believe Christians are
discouraged to drink alcohol but why
does God asked for an alcoholic beverage
in numbers
28:7 as part of the sacrifices yeah when
it talks about the drink offering it's
not talking about an alcoholic drink
they would offer grape juice and even
Christ at the Last Supper he made it
clear that the the grape juice that he
was offering the disciples was not
fermented uh he said in the Kingdom
you'll drink this with me new and that's
in Matthew 26 I believe so uh we also
have a book called alcohol and the
Christian that'll answer that question
if you want a free copy again that
number is 8835 6747 just ask for it it's
called alcohol and the Christian all
right next question uh why is it that
Jesus lost his ability to be omnipresent
although he still is omnipotent and
omniscient now that he's in heaven yeah
well Jesus is Omni presentent in the
sense that he said uh wherever the holy
spirit is he is he said everybody
listening right now when we accept him
he says I am with you always even to the
end of the world so while Christ took on
human form in his body through his
omnisense his all knowing he can be
everywhere all at one time but you just
think about the incredible sacrifice
that he made in that he will forever be
married to the Human family because of
his love for us and the sacrifice that
he made so uh that's a wonderful thing
to consider and friends we look forward
to studying with you more in the uh
coming weeks so just make sure and go to
amazingfacts.org and study and continue
to listen to Bible answers
live Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions